[MUSIC]
I think you can gain a measure of
success coming from either the bottom up
or the top down, but
I think there's a limitation.
So, I think it really it
takes the whole village.
We can start from the bottom, and
we can get a measure of success.
You can automate infrastructure.
You can start to spread some
knowledge about those practices.
You can start from the top.
You can mandate.
Or you can
try to create
an environment in which you
are looking to avoid snowflakes
in your production environment.
And that kind of messaging
will go some way.
But at some point,
you need a common or shared goal.
I think this is where the XP principle
of a shared metaphor is really important
organizationally.
You want everyone to understand the
context around what better looks like.
And I think that that can't come
just from the line of execution.
In the same way that it
cannot come from the top.
I think in lean there's this idea of
going to the place where the work
happens.
It's going to the gamba.
And I think that's a great metaphor for
how the leadership in an organization
and the line of execution can
come together to make a DevOps
transformation super effective.